oh [ __ ] de bordel de merde en fichez
emmerdes en bordel c'est pas beau hein
tous ces gros mots dans la bouche d'une
femme c'est ce que tous les parents
répète aux petites filles ça se fait pas
pour une fille si pas beau peut-être
mais moi je pense au contraire que tous
ces gros mots que ces mots d'hommes dans
la bouche des femmes sont indispensables
tout comme madeleine pelletier première
femme française psychiatre en 1905
je crois et je la cite que la
suppression de la servitude féminine
passe par la suppression de la
coquetterie de la retenue de la pudeur
exagérée des mièvreries de l'esprit et
du langage
j'aimerais ne plus jamais entendre une
fille ne fait pas ça il faut s'asseoir
correctement mais cela n'a rien à voir
avec le fait d'être une fille c'est
juste plus polis il faut éviter d'élever
la voix
mais pas parce qu'on est une fille juste
parce qu'on ne se fait pas entendre en
criant j'aimerais ne plus jamais
entendre un père annoncé à la cantonade
que le premier homme qui s'approchera de
cfi sera décapitée alors qu'il reggae
man au rvaj probable de son fils sur la
gente féminine et j'aimerais encore
moins entendre une mère qui pour calmer
les cris de son fils va tranquillement
lui asséner mais enfin tu va pas pleurer
comme une fille et pourquoi pas il faut
arrêter d'essentialiser les petites
filles il faut cesser de les limiter aux
stéréotypes de genre et pourquoi on
ferait ça a peut-être pour leur donner
la possibilité du choix voire du choix
de l'émancipation sans passer par la
case obligé des qualités dites féminines
la tendresse la douceur l'attention à
autrui la séduction ou même la maternité
et puis un garçon manqué c'est souvent
une fille réussit
je suis née à téhéran avec la révolution
islamique
ma grande chance fut d'avoir grandi dans
une famille athée après la révolution
khomeyniste le voile est devenu
obligatoire pour toutes les femmes mais
aussi pour toutes les petites filles
je me souviens quand on m'a recouvert de
noir le premier jour d'école j'avais 6
ans je voulais pas porter le voile
j'ai crié j'ai pleuré j'ai piétiné mon
voile son succès est finalement la seule
réponse qui s'est imposé à l'enfant que
j'étais fut de montrer mon cul si c'est
tous les jours
après la sonnerie je retirais le voile
et la tenue réglementaire qui allait
avec pour me précipiter dans la cour cul
nu poursuivi par les femmes corbeau qui
trébuché sur les pandores tchador à 6
ans ce spectacle super réjouissant j'ai
aussi monté une troupe de danse
clandestine dans les toilettes de
l'école pour reproduire les
chorégraphies de west side story dont la
vhs circulent au marché noir
et quand nous nous sommes fait
surprendre on se fait toujours
surprendre je me suis justifier en
parlant d'un spectacle de cabaret ce qui
a provoqué illico la convocation de mes
parents à qui la directrice de l'école
une horrible femme qui ne souriait
jamais a remis le numéro d'un exorciste
mes parents ont beaucoup ri mot ici
quand j'ai compris ce que c'était qu'un
exorciste des années ont passées sur le
voile de mon enfance des années durant
lesquelles j'ai pu mettre du sens sur ma
réaction physique et enfantine le voile
sexualis le corps de la femme en le
culte en le voile fait le nid de la
concupiscence
en comparaison le cul nu de mon enfance
était super innocent il absurde de
croire que le voile protège la femme il
la ville l'air habilis et créer une
hiérarchie des femmes de la prude qui le
porte à la [ __ ] qui le refusent et
pourtant les chiffres venus d'egypte
sont confondants 92 % des femmes
ils sont voilées et 96% subissent des
attouchements sauvage dans les rues
la blague qui circule au caire dit que
les 4 % restantes n'était pas chez elle
le jour du sondage
je ne veux pas être une victime je ne
veux pas être toujours en danger
j'en ai marre d'être réduite à mon corps
intime et sexuelle
et c'est le cas depuis très très très
très longtemps
hier c'était le corset et le mariage qui
empêchait le corps féminin de se mouvoir
librement
aujourd'hui c'est le voile et la
sacralisation pour le moins hystérique
de la virginité qui ne discriminent face
à cette oppression l'essentiel à mon
sens pour les femmes pour toutes les
femmes c'est de posséder pleinement leur
corps pour se réapproprier leurs droits
et c'est pour ne jamais l'oublier que je
me répète régulièrement les paroles de
madame de saints-anges dans la
philosophie dans le boudoir du marquis
de sade ton corps est à deux fois et à
toi seul il n'y a que toi seul au monde
qui est le droit d'en jouir et d'en
faire jouir qui bon te semble
c'est beau un sessad
depuis les gynécée grecque ces
appartements réservés aux femmes à
l'intérieur de la maison double
protection pour le corps féminin
toute l'histoire de l'émancipation
féminine peut se lire à travers le
passage progressif du corps féminin de
l'espace privé à l'espace public de
l'invisibilité à la visibilité
le travail le vote la liberté sexuelle
tout cela se joue dans l'espace public
et pourtant on continue d'élever les
petites filles dans la crainte de
l'extérieur on laisse les gars ont joué
dans la rue mais les filles ont les
cantonne à l'intérieur seulement voilà
d'après le ms un tiers des femmes dans
le monde sont victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelles
la très grande majorité de la part de
leurs compagnons à l'intérieur un quart
des américaines subissent des violences
domestiques
toujours à l'intérieur en france d'après
les chiffres du haut conseil à l'égalité
entre hommes et femmes entre 2010 et
83 mille femmes ont été victimes de viol
et de tentative de viol 83%
connaissaient leur agresseur et seuls 11
% hausse porté plainte
et si elle n'ose pas c'est qu'elle se
sente coupable
et si elles se sentent coupables c'est
que leur éducation et leur environnement
les renvoie à cette culpabilité
le philosophe john stuart mill
il en faut toujours un le constatait
déjà en 1851
quand il déclarait que toutes les femmes
sont élevées dès l'enfance dans la
croyance que l'idéal de leur caractère
et le contraire de celui d'un homme
elles sont dressés à ne pas vouloir par
elle même à ne pas se conduire d'après
leur volonté mais à se soumettre
c'est contre cette soumission que je me
bats et le système pour lequel je me
bats est un système égalitaire
il n'est pas question d'un système
matriarcal qui ne règlera aucun problème
mais reproduira les mêmes mécanismes en
miroir et puis une femme ne vaut pas
plus qu'un homme elle vous autant alors
comment faire pour instaurer l'égalité
non parce que franchement en toute
honnêteté c'est un peu la merde quand
même parce que si tout commence à la
maison tout se poursuit à l'école faut
rappeler ici que deux tiers des 775
millions d'analphabètes dans le monde
sont des femmes
les autres toutes celles qui ont la
chance d'aller à l'école sont sujettes à
ce que claude style professeur à
stanford appelle la menace du stéréotype
et qui fonctionne comme une prophétie
auto réalisatrice
en gros parce que les femmes se croient
moins bonne en maths et finissent par le
devenir en france
deux enseignants chercheurs en
psychologie sociale
isabelle regnier pascale huguet ont
demandé à 4 154 élèves de 6e et de 5e de
reproduire une figure qui mêle des
triangles et des carrés de différentes
couleurs
lorsque l'exercice était présenté comme
un exercice de dessins les filles
réussissent mieux que les garçons mais
proposer comme un exercice de géométrie
les gars sont surpassés systématiquement
les filles c'est navrant trice désolant
tragique tout aussi navrante rice
désolant est tragique que les propos
tenus par larry summers président
d'harvard qui déclarait en 2005 que
l'absence des femmes parmi les grands
mathématiciens était liée à des
phénomènes biologiques
c'est pas fini y rajouter les femmes
possédant moins d'aptitude intrinsèques
pour les mathématiques que les hommes
voilà voilà mais cette fois l'histoire
se termine bien parce que c'est
justement une femme d'origine iranienne
mehr y admire haqqani justement diplômé
d'harvard qui lui fermera joyeusement
son clapet en 2014
en devenant la première femme à recevoir
la prestigieuse médaille fields voilà
c'est comme ça que nous avancerons vers
l'égalité en faisant la preuve par notre
compétence notre volonté et notre
ambition
mais pour y parvenir il faut renverser
la table et pour renverser la table il
faut regarder le monde autrement
atterrant j'avais demandé à mon
professeur de religion qui ne nous
regardait jamais nous les filles
pourquoi je devais porter le voile
il avait répondu par un lapidaire parce
que vous êtes vous les femmes des objets
dangereux systems est présent c'est sûr
mais c'était salvateur j'ai 8 ans et je
fais si peur que ça avec mes cheveux mes
poignets mes chevilles de rien du tout
j'ai peur à un type tellement plus vieux
mais alors j'ai des super pouvoirs
toutes les femmes ont des super pouvoirs
ce jour là j'ai décidé de garder mon
super pouvoirs pour ne plus jamais être
réduite un objet voilà comment j'ai
commencé par regarder le monde autrement
en devenant ce sujet et en tant que
sujet pour s'accomplir en tant que sujet
nous avons besoin de notre mémoire et de
notre histoire
à mon arrivée à paris je m'attendais
avoir atterri dans le pays de simone de
beauvoir
je m'attendais à les croiser partout les
simone de beauvoir que mon père m'avait
promis dans la vie et dans les livres
eh bien ils n'étaient pas là elle était
occulté voile est aujourd'hui olympe de
gouges et sa déclaration des droits de
la femme et de la citoyenne sont entrés
dans les manuels scolaires
mais elles sont où toutes les autres
toutes celles qui peuvent être des
références et nous offrir la possibilité
du choix du fameux choix et les ou
hubertine auclert première femme
française à se dire féministe et qui
lança une grève de l'impôt avec ce
slogan génial je ne vote pas je ne paye
pas elle est où jane dieulafoy qui
traversait la perse en 1881 1882 et
apporta sa contribution fondamentale à
l'étude de la perse antique et l'origine
de l'architecturé occidentale
il suffit de se promener au louvre pour
remarquer qu'une salle porte son nom et
c'est travestie en homme que c'est un
soumises a reçu la légion d'honneur à
une époque où le travestissement était
interdite elle est où marguerite durand
féministe syndicaliste rédactrice
journalistes qui lança avec succès le
premier quotidien féminin la fronde
non seulement entièrement écrits mais
aussi fabriqué et distribué par les
femmes et dans les pages duquel il était
davantage questions de politique
internationale et d'économie que de
cuisine et de mode elles sont où
toutes ces femmes incroyables qui nous
ont précédés et qui peuvent excitant en
nous le désir d'aller plus loin que ce
foutu plafond de verre contre lequel
nous nous brisons génération après
génération aujourd'hui autant cuillère
l'obscurantisme s'en prend aux femmes à
leur corps à leurs droits et aujourd'hui
tout autant qu'hier nous avons besoin
des lumières pour nous battre
pas pour nous défendre pour nous battre
les lumières c'est piétiner son héritage
quand il n'est que la somme de nos
préjugés les lumières c'est raisonner en
homme et femme libre et autonome capable
d'exercer notre esprit critique pour
détruire la prison de notre naissance de
notre sexe notre condition sociale
les lumières c'est un appel à
l'insoumission l'insoumission
ça commence par des gros mots dans la
bouche des femmes et des professeurs qui
pousse les filles aller plus loin en
mathématiques
ce sont des pères qui ne craignent pas
la liberté sexuelle de leur fille et des
mères qui se battent pour les envoyer à
l'école et les y maintenir
l'insoumission
c'est le premier pas vers notre
révolution merci